Should cancer patients be gluten-free?
No, I wouldn't say so. No.
Is gluten maybe another question off of this would be is gluten a driver for most cancers? No, it's very
very few cancers
I mean, are there any cancers that serve to feed off of
gluten? However, gluten is a
flammatory for a lot of people a lot of people have gluten since timidies
and would never know unless they did a
gluten
et a body on
lab tests which would be the Syrex array 3x
and then possibly a Syrex array 4
to see if any cross reactants to that
um
Now that doesn't mean that if let's say a cancer patient did a Syrex array 3x and they have antibodies to
gliated peptides so gliated as the is the protein and gluten that people have issues with
and as it breaks down into smaller particles of amino acid
products which are called peptides before it gets down to the individual amino acid
you can have you can develop antibodies against those peptides and then every time you eat gluten
it causes inflammation. Now how would that relate to cancer? You know there are a few people that
I tell to stay off of gluten or to limit gluten
but it's mainly because in the testing that it came up as an issue with the cancer and it's most
likely it's because it's inflammatory so if the person does have peptides and they let's say they
show up in the cheek swab test as they should stay off of gluten and I've listed that in a food that
you should eliminate with your particular protocol it's most likely because it's inflammatory
to you and it's causing issues if we would do the Syrex 3x it would probably be positive we'd
probably have positive antibody peptides and antibodies to different pleated peptides so that's why
should all cancer patients be gluten free again I wouldn't say so should everybody limit gluten
even if they if they have cancer it would be a good idea and again the reason is that it's
it's inflammatory we don't need any extra you know daily inflammation you can the more daily
inflammation that you can get rid of the better off you're going to be for your cancer the better
off you're going to be for your whole body the better off you're going to be for your brain health
big time so just so you know if you have any brain health issues just about all the
proteins that you could have antibodies against in the brain like myelin sheath proteins or
different proteins that would be a precursor for dementia or Alzheimer's issues or Parkinson's
issues or any demilinated diseases they all are molecular mimics to gluten pretty much
most of them are molecular mimics to gluten so you really cannot be on gluten if you have any
brain fog issues dementia issues you really should limit gluten if you have any emotional issues
let's say OCD issues or anxiety issues or depression issues you really should be off of gluten if
you have any thyroid issues you should absolutely be off of gluten because for the added and its
peptides are molecular mimics to the thyroid plant so there's a lot of reasons why people should not
be eating gluten but you can't say that all cancer patients absolutely have to be off gluten
gluten is almost never a feeder of the cancer it's the inflammatory issues with gluten that we have